non content et la propre cardinalice
c'est vrai que ses habits neufs des
cardinaux ne manque pas de classe 7
pourpre est capable de transfigurer
n'importe quel homme moyen lorsqu'on le
voit dans un habit de ville tout à fait
ordinaire en fait la tradition on
n'empêche pas une certaine mode com va
vous le montrer jean-claude d'arrigo
comme dans la ville éternelle la
clientèle ecclésiastique existe c'est
connu en quantité tout à fait notoire
les magasins spécialisés sans être aussi
nombreux que les supermarchés fleuriste
au coin des rues à l'occasion de leur
nomination à l'épiscopat ou au
cardinalat les prélats viennent
s'approvisionner ici avant de retourner
dans leurs diocèses de france ou
d'ailleurs dans ces lieux on parle
soutane mis très cross avec autant de
naturel que d'autres parlent chiffon
combien ça peut coûter une calotte comme
celle ci je suis là dix mille lire on
n'y arrive plus tout est hors de prix
alto monseigneur cela revient vraiment
cher d'avoir les vêtements les ornements
adéquat quand on devient évêque cardinal
oh oui ça coûte les yeux de la tête on
est obligé d'acheter du noir du violet
du rouge
une vraie galère c'est mieux alors
d'être un prêtre tout court non qu'il y
a de mieux c'est d'être ce que le bon
dieu veut que l'on soit et puis si doux
chez nous le prix d'une soudaine de
cardinal commence aux alentours de 200
250 me lire cela dépend de la qualité du
tissu que l'on emploie après il y à la
mode est le plastron la ceinture la
calotte disons qu'on arrive pour un jeu
complet de vêtements cardinalice à
500000 lire environ 2500 francs encore
une fois cela dépend de ce que vous
voulez comme qualité de tissu que falla
walikale oui mais il n'ya pas que cela
un cardinals apporte d'autres choses des
caps de soi moiré des traînes des
fourrures des croix en or et en diamant
ne sont ils pas les princes de l'église
détrompons-nous tout a bien changé c'est
le cardinal du si jésus parle en
fouillant le grenier de l'archevêché de
paris
il dit j'ai trouvé plein de choses
appartenant à mes prédécesseurs je sais
que mes collègues cardinaux ont fait de
même dans leur propre grenier
heureusement pour nous d'ailleurs
notre génération a autre chose à faire
qu'à s'encombrer de fallu à la et de
dépenses inutiles